nous sommes avec thierry lardinoit
médecin généraliste président de la
caisse autonome de retraite des médecins
de france bonsoir monsieur l'art de noix
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
force alors c'est un feuilleton à
rebondissements décidément l'om est ce
qui annonce ce soir la reprise des
essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine ça ressemble
voilà un vrai cafouillage pour le moins
oui c'est un cafouillage et puis à
lorsqu'il va m'étonner mois terriblement
on sait que le ministre écrivent
aujourd'hui pour demander aux l'ancêtre
des comptes sur cette étude
j'ai envie de lui dire monsieur le
ministre que les navets vous fait plutôt
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas demander aux
lans est une expression correcte et
approfondie de cette étude avant de
suspendre les essais thérapeutiques avec
cette hydre de six bureaux qui n'a t'on
pas fait perdre des chances à un certain
nombre de patients en suspendant ses
études aussi rapidement ça moi c'est ma
question et c'est pas la seule c'est pas
la seule parce que moi je m'interroge
pourquoi depuis le début s'acharne-t-on
à instruire qu'à charge contre l'hydre
aussi clan qui c'est à dire que on ne se
donne et c'est uniquement d'utiliser les
docks cycle eurokin dans des phases de
la maladie où on sait pertinemment
qu'elle n'est plus efficace et toutes
les études sorte à charge évidemment
puisqu'on l'utilisent dans des phases où
ça ne fonctionne pas moi je m'interroge
pourquoi monsieur le ministre n'utilise
ont pâli roxy chloroquine et ne fait-on
pas des essais comme le professeur comme
toul a proposé à la phase initiale et
comme je voulais également au monde pro
nous proposer sur un essai compassionnel
puisqu'on ne vont vous proposer que les
médecins essayent de façon compassionnel
sur eux-mêmes l'hydroxyde chloroquine et
l'azithromycine pour voir si ça
fonctionnait je m'interroge pourquoi ça
n'est pas fait je m'interroge
vous vous interrogez mais quand on
s'interroge souvent on a des débuts de
réponse selon vous le ministre de la
santé a péché par quoi par un excès de
précaution par excès de crédulité quand
il a lu cette annonce à champ qu'il est
évidemment médecin lui-même où il y
avait d'autres peut-être motivation de
la part de nice voir d'autres pressions
c'est lui qu'il faudrait interroger moi
je ne me permettrais pas de mettre en
cause un confrère
j'ose imaginer qu'en tant que médecin il
a à coeur de soigner les français et que
c'est son c'est le coeur de sa volonté
le coeur du choix qu'il a fait le coeur
des engagements de sa vie donc je ne me
permettrais en aucun cas de mettre en
cause je m'interroge je veux dit
pourquoi une telle puissance et un tel
acharnement à discréditer cette molécule
est à aucun moment de se mettre en
situation de vérifier des hypothèses
- quand quand une hypothèse se présente
dans ma vie professionnelle ou dans ma
vie personnelle je me mets en état de la
vérifier
et puis si ça fonctionne pas
effectivement ça ne fonctionne pas
là on se met dans une situation où on
sait que ça fonctionnera pas et on me
dira vous avez vu ça fonctionne pas oui
bien sûr on n'en ont sans doute moi je
suis ce que j'ai dit sur une autre
chaîne de médias c'est à savoir qu'un
étudiant de troisième année de médecine
c'est très bien qu'on utilisera une
molécules antivirales au tout début de
la maladie et que ça ne sert à rien de
l'utiliser enfin de maladies au milieu
de maladie la face d'état est une phase
dépassé en ce qui concerne les
pathologies virales c'est connu c'est
pas quelque chose de spectaculaire a
encore une fois n'importe quel étudiant
en troisième année de médecine peut vous
fournir cette réponse
donc quand on voit que absolument tout
le monde s'acharne à l'utiliser enfin
d'évolution pour nous dire qu'elle se
sera pas efficace
ce que l'on sait parfaitement il n'y a
pas besoin de faire des études pour ça
je m'interroge
alors c'est vrai qu'on nous a aussi dit
sa faim scientifique d'ailleurs on en a
invité toute erreur scientifique
lui-même laurent alexandre qui voilà qui
exprimé des doutes puisque plusieurs
scientifiques nous ont dit voilà c'est
potentiellement dangereux notamment sur
la scop cardiaque
ça c'est pas sérieux c'est pas sérieux
on est sur une molécule qui est en vente
libre le 13 janvier vous allez le 13
janvier la pharmacie vous acheter quatre
boîtes diderot cycloclean on vous les
donne sans vous poser de questions le 14
on voulait il faut une ordonnance et le
15 mars vous ne pouvez plus la voir même
avec une ordonnance mais il faut savoir
que jusqu'au 13 janvier c'est une
molécule qui apparaît dans les années 50
et qui est donc a été prescrit à 1
milliard 500 millions d'individus
si jamais la molécule était dangereuse
ça se saurait ça serait ça serait ça
serait ressorti de façon de façon pas
tant ça c'est cette accusation n'est pas
sérieuse et il ne tient pas la route
d'ailleurs si on revoit les ont fait une
méta analyse des renseignements de de la
haute autorité de santé
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
2017 si mes souvenirs sont bons jusqu'à
2020 il est décrit deux accidents graves
à l'hydroxyde le rockin dont une
intoxication volontaire et là encore une
fois on sait parfaitement la dangerosité
de vitraux de sic leur quine en
intoxication volontaire puisqu'on sait
que c'est une molécule qui présentent un
danger mais comme beaucoup d'autres
comme beaucoup d'autres je peux je peux
vous citer une dizaine de molécules qui
sont vendus qui sont prescrites chez des
patients et si on les utilise à des
doses papa très importante
on a des accidents graves et mortels et
ils sont toujours commercialisés
donc le sérieux de mettre en cause
identique turquie ne tient pas la route
ça tient absolument c'est un problème
purement franco français on rappelle que
de nombreux pays dans le monde
mais quand on regarde moi je j'exerce en
moselle en si on compare la population
de moselle la population du luxembourg
elle à peu près équivalente et la
mortalité est cette fois plus importante
en moselle
c'est quand même et manifestement
luxembourg a utilisé les tropiques le
rocking ont de façon plus ou plus ou
moins discrète il ya il ya un problème
avec la drogue thick lors qu'il ya un
problème non pas de la molécule non pas
de son efficacité
mais il ya un problème il existe une
chape de plomb sur son usage problème
politique
certains ne veulent pas qu'on utilise
cette molécule pour des raisons que
j'ignore ce que gym et c'est pas mon
problème
moi je suis médecin généraliste vous
savez mon idée à moi c'est de me dire
quand un patient est malade je le soigne
mois mais même moi poignet mais m n'ont
pas appris à attendre les autorisations
de l'om est ce d'ailleurs qui va dans un
sens marche avant marche arrière ou
d'attendre qu'un ministre me disent oui
vous avez raison vous allez fais moi je
suis dans un bureau avec un patient qui
est malade il faut qu'en dix minutes
j'ai eu une réponse efficace pour le
soigner et qui durent donc moi j'ai
appris à traiter des patients comme ça
en trente ans d'exercice je crois qu'ils
ont été globalement satisfaits et des
piles et puis voilà
merci en tout cas de série alors de noix
médecin généraliste président également
de la caisse autonome de retraite des
médecins de france d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir apporté votre point de vue